Escribir una desigualdad que se ajuste a la gráfica
que se muestra abajo
así que nos han dibujado una línea en rojo
y la desigualdad incluye esta línea,
porque está en rojo...
y no en una, digamos, línea punteada,
así que todo lo que tenemos que hacer es
hallar el área de arriba
con una "y" que sea mayor o igual
a esta línea roja,
así que lo que primero tenemos que hacer,
es encontrar la ecuación de la línea
y lo podemos ver en esta intersección con el eje "y"...
dejenme hacerlo en un color más oscuro...
esta es la intersección con el eje "y" que es,
0, -2
así que si pensamos en esta línea y
si pensamos en la ecuación
de la forma "y" igual a "mx" más "b"
que es la forma eh...
pendiente ordenada al origen,
entonces tenemos que "b" es -2
ajá...
y pensemos en la pendiente ahora
esto si nos movemos 2 unidades a la derecha
en la dirección "x"
es decir, si delta "x" es igual a 2
entonces nuestro cambio en "x" es positivo y es 2
¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "y"?
nuestro cambio en "y" es -1 ¿verdad?
porque baja una unidad
así que la pendiente o "m"...
"m" es igual a delta "y" sobre delta "x"
que es igual a -1 sobre 2
que es igual a -1/2
y sólo para confirmar esto,
ya lo hemos hecho en otros lados,
también podríamos haber dicho bueno
¿qué tal si nos vamos hacia atrás en "x", 4 unidades?
es decir ¿qué pasa si me cambio en "x" o delta "x"
es igual a -4?
entonces delta "y" sería
sería 2 ¿verdad?
2 positivo
y otra vez delta "y" sobre delta "x"
sería igual a 2
sobre -4
que también es igual a -1/2,
esto sólo fue para confirmar
que no depende de qué tanto nos movemos
en la dirección "x"
si nos vamos adelante o atrás, siempre vamos a tener que la pendiente es la misma
y es -1/2
así que la ecuación de esta línea es,
"y" igual a pendiente que es -1/2,
por "x" más "b" que es -2
así que esta es la ecuación
de esta línea justo de aquí.
Ahora la desigualdad incluye esta línea y todo lo que está arriba de este valor para cualquier "x"
digamos que para "x" igual a 1
esta línea nos dice bueno,
te tomas el punto,
bueno...
déjenme poner a "x" igual a 2 para...
para que sea más sencillo, entonces,
cuando "x" es igual a 2 este valor nos da
-1/2 por 2 que es -1 y menos 2
nos da al final -3
pero esta desigualdad no sólo es "y" igual a -3
porque también podemos tomarnos cualquier
otro valor arriba de -3
y sabemos esto porque estamos sombreando toda esa área ¿verdad? así que la ecuación...
o más bien la desigualdad que ajusta la gráfica...
que estamos mostrando,
¿ok? sería "y" mayor o igual que
-1/2 por "x" menos 2
esta es la desigualdad que, digamos,
que representa esta gráfica,
y bueno esto es solo la línea,
pero cuando queremos
toda el área arriba de la línea
es cuando tomamos esta desigualdad